foreign
BJ's with us in Chesapeake Virginia hi
BJ how are you hi Dave I'm doing good
I'm over here cleaning up our empty
house so but I'm good sounds like a side
hustle to me
it is it is I love it good good money
how can we help
well my question was I do have these
rentals and I have to pay IRS somewhere
fifteen thousand thirty thousand every
year so my question is should I take
Equity out just so out some of them are
paid for so I'm concerned about taking
Equity out just to try to have other
deductions or should I just continue to
pay our IRS I don't know
okay uh there are no tax deductions that
make mathematical sense
because if you give the government I
mean if you give the bank ten thousand
dollars and it is a tax deduction
because it was interest on us on a loan
that means you get to deduct ten
thousand dollars from your income so you
do not have to pay taxes on that ten
thousand dollars it does not save you
ten thousand dollars in taxes
it saves you having to pay taxes on ten
thousand dollars of your income and so
if you're in a 25 tax bracket it saves
you twenty five hundred dollars so you
gave the bank ten thousand dollars to
keep from sending the IRS 2500 that's
called stupid
okay we don't want to do that very well
we're not trading dollars for quarters
and look at that and call that
sophisticated financial planning okay
people do that crap all the time though
and some CPAs are so stupid they
recommend you do that but you don't want
to do it okay now here here's the thing
why do you owe the IR you have a day job
other than the rentals I don't work I
mean I retire at 2020. okay so you've
got income from retirement that's
taxable
mm-hmm and you've got the Rev and you've
got to rinse off these properties that's
taxable
well I have other income that I worked
for I'm retired military so I get income
from that and that's taxation from the
post office I got money from that and
that's taxable
and I get the rental income and then I
get I'm 100 disabled that's not taxable
from the middle that's not that's not
everything else is though okay cool
right so here's what's happening you
just owe income tax
and you aren't setting it aside out of
your check
so if you owe 30 000 bucks a year that's
2500 bucks a month you need to be
setting aside
in your little IRS savings fund over
here
okay you have to withhold on yourself
so that this doesn't come up smack you
in the back of the head every year
because if every time every year it
smacks you in the back of the head you
run borrow on it that's going to run out
that's right yeah okay
yeah using the home equity loan would
just be kicking the can down the road
you'd just be basically taking from
yourself in the long run so you've got
income that's taxable north of 100 grand
yes way to go
thank you for your service by the way
well thank you thank you yeah I mean
you've got you've you so what are you 60
69 69 okay all right yeah so you know
what what you need to do is sit down
with a tax professional just go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on tax ELP
because they need to help you set up a
cash flow schedule that every month when
you get checks you take some of that and
before you even put it in your you put
in a checking account or whatever but
immediately it moves uh X number of
dollars over as if you were doing a
double like you when you worked at the
post office they held money out of your
check right so you just got to hold
money out of your own check so this
doesn't keep smacking you all the time
okay you're amazing you put together
quite a life here
so don't put the on any of the ones that
you don't recommend equity line on any
of my paid off properties I paid off
four of them is free and clear no I
wouldn't no you have the money to pay
the taxes right now that are due
oh of course yeah I'll pay all the bills
everything is paid for savings is coming
in you know um so no so your main
question is do I go in debt to lower my
tax bill
but see even if I did that get an equity
I could buy another property
yes but you would be in debt and now
you've done all of this because this tax
thing is bothering you and if you owe
the bank ten thousand dollars in
interest you only save twenty five
hundred dollars on taxes bad trade again
okay so I I would rather see you uh set
up a schedule where your taxes are
coming out of your check that yours
taking them out automatically and and
you're not getting you're not feeling
the pinch of these things because you're
planning better number one and then I
want you to use some of this money
because you don't spend much money and I
think you're going to be able to pile up
enough cash pretty quickly to buy
another property with cash and not have
any debt
uh-huh there's a reason you work to get
all these paid off kiddo yeah
because life's better when they're paid
off don't go back in debt
yeah okay yeah you're feeling the
pressure from the tax thing because it's
just bad cash planning is you got bad
cash planning yeah BJ you're such a rock
star just even the fact that right now
when you called you said you're at the
rental cleaning it yourself at 69 years
old like you have worked hard for this
then that's incredible just keep doing
what you're doing because you have prove
that you know what you're doing and you
can't borrow your way out of this you
got you gotta plan and work your way out
of it and and that's that's a thing but
it's a misnomer that and you can only
write off interest by the way if you're
itemizing and most people don't itemize
anymore the standard deductions are so
high very few people itemize so it's
really mythology I'm going to stay in
debt on my home because I get a tax
write off you really don't you know if
you're taking standard deduction you
don't get a tax write-off on your own
because your standard deductions covered
you got that whether you had to debt or
not